I'd love to see Michael Kelso
[Music]
you don't want me to go to the concert
is that it I didn't know if you liked
music Michael
I didn't invite you to the concert
because I know you really don't like my
friends did you tell them that no
Michael don't tell our proper
conversation so that people might go we
have to have the conversations
also I didn't think you'd be interested
in Todd Rundgren I mean like you said
he's no Frampton
I love Todd Wonder men I have the 45 of
hello it's me
remember the night we listened to it we
can't have fun at the concert that's
especially in the car in the way back
okay you can go
only if you want me to
oh I want to jacket
I guess you're going to the concert with
us
I can't wait
so Michael
you want to go back to my house and
listen to Grunion records yeah sure
bye
Jackie Michael you've been sprung
you don't know what it's like on the
inside Jackie
yeah
damn those police oh no it was high but
he really frogged me
oh poor baby
it's Jackie
okay so let's do this thing
this is the Mr the pen war the pirate
shirt of the Wind
what about the banner
it's okay
the important thing is
I'm here with you
and I'm prepared to give myself to you
body mind and soul
Michael this is going to be the most
magical night of our lives
oh yeah and one more thing
my parents are the amp so I'm only have
like 15 minutes
[Music]
foreign
hello Michael
hello Jackie
I'm just over here helping Donnie get
ready for the prom
because Eric and Donna are going to the
prom
yes we are
I'm going to the prom
I'm taking Pat Macy
oh the
[Applause]
who is it
what's his name his name is
not important what's important is he's
better than you in every conceivable way
damn Jackie that could be anybody
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I'm from my books
Michael We're Not Gonna study
no
my parents are going to be gone for
hours
oh
so
what do you want to do
[Music]
[Applause]
oh check it out Bowie
man he's cool yeah
androgynous guys are so manly
Michael do you know who would look
totally totally sexy glammed up like
Bowie
oh you Michael
you're crazy
no I'm not Glam come on Michael you have
such pretty eyes
oh my lashes do go out like a mile
with this
I can flip them up
oh wait
wait stupid shut up Michael I'm almost
done
I can't believe I let you talk me into
this
okay here take a look
okay yeah my eyes are gorgeous
see see I told you
Michael do you know what you need now
some blush
Jackie
Glam is one thing but I think we're
crossing over into weird
no no trust me Michael we're not
cheekbones like that blush is your best
friend
yeah I do a and cheekbones
okay let's blush
[Music]
oh God like on that dress you are way
prettier than Bowie well I'm prettier
than you
that's not my mind
[Music]
did you use your car pull off relax
Jackie your parents aren't supposed to
be home for like another hour
spinning
hi daddy we're studying
I love him
Michael I don't want to talk to you no
you're right okay because words don't do
it that's why I wrote this song oh God
oh
Jackie please take me back in
I'll get the next
stop
Michael stop yes please cancel stop
I cannot take this anymore this is how
you serenade a woman
this summer
[Music]
what are you doing
yeah what are you doing
um this is my school song from back home
I don't love you
hey what's going on
nothing
nothing at all
thank you Hyde for tonight
it was very special
bye
isn't she nice
it's kind of cold oh here
take my jacket I love you God we are
such the
perfect couple
I'm cold too well damn Jackie I can't
control the weather
here Jackie
take my coat
oh thanks Fez
sweetie what do you want to do whatever
you want to do honey I want to go inside
that's what I want to do too oh my god
let's go
what the hell was that jacket business
man you're making me look bad
look at some you are my good friend but
I will stop at nothing to win Jackie and
if you're in my way I will destroy you
hi Kelso
hi Tiffany I'm so glad I ran into you
I've been meaning to ask you something
yeah what's that will you take me back
to your house and make out with me
well I
I don't know yeah I'm here to meet
Jackie
I promise you'll never find out
be an afternoon of secret make out fun
you can drink grape juice from my belly
button
this guy you want to Jackie's test
I mean Tiffany never comes on to me
but what if it's not I mean let's face
it I look good today and the new
conditioner is really working out
all right but the real question is
should I risk it and my body says yes
and my head says yes
my heart says no
my stupid heart's right
I can't I mean
I appreciate the offer and all because
you're like really hot
but the only girl I want to make out
which is Jackie so
foreign
Michael now I know I can honestly trust
you with all my heart
oh
um
Jackie
Donna told me about the test
so I knew what was going on and I didn't
say anything
so maybe I don't deserve to be with you
because
that wasn't very honest of me
but telling me that was
damn
you're right
so you'll take me back
I'd love to see Michael Kelso
[Music]
Mr and Mrs Foreman
you're long and happy marriage
got me thinking about my future
and when I think about my future there's
always someone special in it
I mean besides me so
in front of all the people that I love
Jacqueline Burkhart will you marry me
oh Michael
no congratulations what the hell
no no
Jackie
you would have just made me the happiest
man in the world
[Applause]
oh man I mean I love you and all but
it's like that's like the worst idea
I've ever had
and I've had some bad ideas I mean a
firecracker suit like what the hell was
that
the best fourth of June ever that's what
Michael if you and I got married it
would be a disaster I mean I love you
but you have so much going up to do oh
and I do not want a box of puppies
running around and I do oh man this is
like my life is finally taking off I'm
moving to Chicago don't I hope I did the
right thing yo I'm so happy I'm gonna
jump off the roof
you did the right thing
[Music]
foreign